[Music]
[Music]
here in this video we will showcase the
two dragons that are seen in the house
of the dragon reign of fire just the
ones that were seen in the first episode
minus spoilers alert be ready so let's
get to it let's start with the first one
cyrax
this is a she dragon that is mounted by
princess renera targaryen the first born
daughter of king viserys the first so
let's take a quick look at her lore from
the books and then discuss how she is
portrayed in the live action series
her name was derived from a valyrian
goddess cyrex was a young dragon with
the yellow scales although she was large
and strong the other one karaxis was
more frightful and skilled in combat
xyrax was fed lavishly even while she
was being restrained in shackles and
when the civil war broke out she had not
hunted for years as she was housed
inside the walls of the red keep in
king's landing in a stable in the outer
wall that had been cleared of horses and
designated for her use she was confined
to the floor by thick chains but then
she could go between the stable and the
yard thanks to the lengthy chains but
they were also the ones that prevented
her from taking off without a rider
so in the first episode we saw cyrax
flying across the sky above king's
landing with renera on top of her sarax
was the first dragon scene in the show
and she was the size of drogon and the
fighting pits of meereen which means
still a small dragon not as terrifying
as the three in the later seasons of
game of thrones but still she was pretty
powerful and was a very fast and agile
flyer she was very loyal and quite
attached to princess rhaenyra as seen in
the opening scenes of the episode and
then later on when they were in
dragonstone cyrax brought great
resemblance to drogon viserion and regal
in terms of body shape and scales as
well as horns with the only difference
is her coloration
the other dragon here is keraxis and
this is the dreaded blood worm of prince
daemon targaryen the younger brother of
king viserys the first so let's take a
quick look at its lore from the books
and then discuss how he is portrayed in
life action series also called the blood
worm for his appearance color and body
shape he was first written by prince
aemon targaryen and then later when he
died damon took on the red beast to be
his mount state or companion
karaxis was a large slender and red
dragon he was formidable terrifying and
skilled in warfare karaxis was around
one half the size of the enormous veigar
during the dance of the dragons he was
regarded by the dragon keepers as being
the most vicious of all the dragon pits
juvenile dragons caraxies had been
designated as prince daemon targaryen's
mount and when damon fled from king's
landing for dragonstone he brought the
paramour of his masseria along with him
on the back of karaxis
this dragon was seen in the later scenes
of the first episode and characters was
very different from the other dragons
seen in the show while the others were
very bulky and had a huge chest or upper
torso
this bloodworm stayed true to its name
he was serpentine in shape much like the
body of smaug the golden from the hobbit
of course
which means he had a snake-like body
with an enlarged chest and two massive
wings plus legs that seem to have skin
or webbings or secondary wings attached
to the beginning of the tail from the
inside ends karaxis was very attached to
daemon and loves to be caressed by him
the dragon was indeed bigger than cyrax
but not as big as drogon
was in the final seasons of game of
thrones maybe as big as viserion or
rhaegal in their final days
so comparing them both side by side
cyrax was bronze or maybe even yellow in
color while caraxes was red cyrax was
more of a conventional type of dragon
while karaxis indeed lived up to the
name of a worm which is a serpentine
dragon karaxis was as big as vasarin was
when he was turned into an undead dragon
while cyrax was only as big as drogon in
the fighting pits of marine
so yeah that's about it on the
comparison of these two dragons
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe as well but most
of all smash the bell icon for regular
updates on new videos here on this
channel till the next one take care fam